Barrett's no offense mate but next time
I'll jump when I damn well want to what
I'm afraid of heights tough guy get some
good shot too
at least I don't think with my weapon I
had Kentucky cold I was in control
you're here to follow orders not
improvise
next time you go off-book we'll leave
your sorry ass for the Russkies
as much as I like your company I don't
have time to chat Namir wants me to
follow up on the debrief with him get
the hell out of my face
I want you to tell me the truth about
operation Rain Bird can't ask he was
never involved was he you used me to
kill him
you're a very good soldier Ben but
there's something you learned enlighten
me
you can't see where the line is you
don't know how to compartmentalize
yourself you're not willing to make that
sacrifice that's what we have to do put
up walls around the parts of our souls
we want to keep sacrosanct barriers to
protect our humanity
we'll kill it it's what we're best is
that what you do you're one man in here
with us out there you're someone else an
assassin a liar that's not something to
be proud of that's a pattern of
psychosis you're very good at what you
do then but inside the weak can let go I
thought that might change after what
happened in Australia I had Holmes
you were part of that I want you to
think very carefully about what you say
next because this is the most important
choice you will ever make
what happened in Moscow that was not a
test of your character or your loyalty
this is the test this is what will
define who you are and your future with
violence you understand I need to know
if you can be like me like the rest of
art like you you don't hide your
humanity here you just tell yourself you
do but you lost it a long time ago you
and Barrett fed her over and the others
you're just a weapon that thinks like a
man that's a shame I really wanted you
to understand I hate to see great
potential waste tell me what you did I
want the trade wish I could make it
clear how lucky you are
recruitment into the tyrants is not a
reward that just anyone is given you
were on a radar for a long time before I
came to you in Australia I gave you the
opportunity to be something greater than
the falsified mission data you had it
substituted for the real thing how we
have assets inside the belltower
corporation it wasn't difficult those
men in your squad they were a hindrance
to you they had to be sacrificed it was
your trial by fire
if you had perished there in the desert
alongside them then you had no place
with us but if you came out of law I
tried to save Sam Duarte I could have
saved his life he was expendable they
all were I gave the order to sabotage a
rainbow because I needed to know if you
were willing to lose if you had the
courage to survive you heartless [ __ ]
bastard survivor's guilt the
psychological profile said that was all
I needed to control but these things are
so hard to determine
I'm pleased I could prove you wrong
you